I sent you to the Royal Wedding simple
instructions
don't cause an international incident
how's it going
you've done some pretty stupid things in
your day but this thanks for cake
[Music]
Henry shoved me an urge I currently
share
what I need is some good old-fashioned
damage control
the White House and the palace are going
to release a joint statement
gotta be choking you can hate Prince
Henry all you want Mandy is bigger than
yours I want you to know that they're
wearing lifts no not too sweetheart you
better act like the Sunshine's out of
his ass and you have a vitamin D
deficiency I think excellent is what you
might say to convince the world about
Ashley friends I love hanging out with
this guys
[Music]
you're expecting at my New Year's party
did I do something wrong do you wonder
who you'd be if you were an anonymous
person in the world I have no idea what
you're talking about you're as thick as
it gets
[Music]
I miss you
when I really really good morning we are
in a hotel crawling with reporters if
anyone sees you leave this hotel I will
brexit your head from your body
your Royal Highness
you figure out if you forever about him
do you love him what difference
Henry belongs to Britain we can figure
out a way to love each other on our own
terms it's like there's a rope attached
to my chest and it keeps pulling me
towards you
hopefully we'll get through tonight
without any more scandals
the night is young ma that's what I want